now that you know about branches and
reach ability you know everything you
need to in order to understand the
entire detached head message we saw
earlier remember to get this message we
checked out a commit not a branch
remember that head just means current
commit so head now points to this commit
first get says that you can look around
and make experimental changes and commit
them you now know that gets history can
be nonlinear so if you commit changes
they would look like what we saw before
here and head we get updated to the
commit that you just made next it says
that you can discard any commits that
you make in this state without impacting
any branches since this commit isn't
included in any branches it won't show
up and get luck it's not reachable and
the changes made here don't show up in
any of the branches and like we said
before if you then checked out an actual
branch it would basically be like this
commit never existed the next bit says
that if you want to create a new branch
to retain these commits you can do so by
using this command get checkout - be new
branch name running git checkout - be is
equivalent to running two commands first
it's just like running git branch new
branch name and then running get
checkout on that new branch since this
sequence of commands is something that
people will want to do pretty often
pretty much every time you're making a
new feature it's nice that there's this
shortcut for it if we do either version
of these commands while we're still on
this commit then the new branch would be
created here then any further commits
would be on this new branch since we
already know that making new commits
brings the branch with us this last line
just reminds us what commit were on by
giving us a shortened version of the
commit ID and then tells us what the
commit message was great now you
understand the entire warning